[Music]
hello and welcome this is Peter here
from Lords of gaming dotnet and from
iron Lords podcast here and we were with
Tom we are learning today about tangled
Tower so Tom how are you doing really
good
pax is intense this is our first PAX
ever in any capacity so it's a lot but
we're happy to hear it now why don't you
tell us about tangle Tower
sure it's a murder mystery detective
adventure game
I think Phoenix right meet Professor
Layton so you wonder about interviewing
suspects finding clues solving puzzles
in the style facility and the prime
suspect is a portrait I'm sorry the what
okay okay unfinished painting so yeah it
sounds a little tricky to get some
information a portrait so so tell us
about you know get out the company like
tell us about you know your development
team so the company is myself and my
brother Adam SSP games and we then
usually hire a couple of our incredibly
talented friends we're just super lucky
to know a whole bunch of really talented
people so we we hired Catherine younger
as the artist for this game and our
friend Jonathan
Harris who did the animation which
you'll see is like next-level incredible
stuff and then we had a composer Raphael
and then the voice actors the whole
things fully voiced every line of
dialogue all 10,000 of them every wised
every line which was a very silly idea
for a two-man company but we did it and
it came out great I think you'll pay off
so and we made a game called snip
Eclipse with Nintendo
it was a launch title and that actually
stopped us from making this game we
started making this game got four months
in and then had to stop because Nintendo
said do you want to make a game with us
and we said yes oh and then Taylor says
yes yes you do you don't really can't
say no so we stopped everything to make
mr. big lips for about two years and
then got back on this and luckily we
still really loved what we started like
I think a lot of times you could go away
for two years and come back and be like
it's not as good as I want but actually
we really like this so he carried on and
finished it up what was this like a
passion project for you guys oh yeah
definitely
I think we just really wanted to make it
the game and so that's why we spent like
the extra time and attention to really
just make it the best thing it could be
I will say though we we were an apple
arcade launch title for this one and if
we hadn't had that deadline of the Apple
arcade launch we might still be making
this game so I'm super grateful for that
deadline to come along and sort of
pushed us to just tie things are
polishing off as best as we could and
get it out in people's hands
great great fantastic so I think we're
looking at some some content here once
you I want you to tell us a little bit
about what's going on and how's it going
and looks like you made with unity is
that what that song says absolutely so
we is our second ever unity game we had
to learn it there's no flavor so yeah
just early scenes here just exploring
the gardens around the the tower itself
the game largely quite takes place
inside
to towered mansion that is the home of
two families who don't necessarily get
along very well and it's a surrounding
gardens as well so you just progress
through the rooms and take a look at
what you can find pick up clues along
the way eventually you'll bump into the
people the other suspects themselves
you'll start finding puzzles and all
sorts of stuff buried away in there so
when you when you guys decided to do
this what was like the like it looks
like you haven't here for the iPad but
what other platforms are you running up
by having this on its own Nintendo
switch and it's on Steam for Windows and
Mac we built it straight away as a
multi-platform game we always designed
it to be playable on a touchscreen and
with a mouse and with a controller and
actually motion pointing on the switch
as well really so did you find that to
be like really difficult to be able to
have to do it for like you know a
touchscreen in addition to you know the
mouse and click option no I think
because we designed it that way before
we'd even put a game together you know
actually did literally the very first
thing I did upon opening a brand new
unity project was build a system to
unify my mouse clicking and touchscreen
and like using an analog stick to move a
cursor about just make a system that
very solidly goes I don't care what
you're pointing with I just care what
you're pointing at and so that set us in
really good stead so it then flowed
really
what was the what was kind of like the
hardships always like the hardest thing
that you had with this project other
than having to wait
other than Nintendo going hey we need
you to make us a game well absolutely I
think just for me I'm so in the
programmer and my brothers the bright
creative director in general my biggest
challenge was the animation system I
really went hard on that to make sure
that the atom and the animator Jonathan
had incredible like flexibility in how
they animate the conversations so I
spent looking great I will say that the
animations and the artistic work that
it's done on this it looks beautiful
looks really clean crisp did a very good
job okay well I like to say thank you
very much for taking the time out to let
us take a look at this interesting
tangle Tower and you know really
appreciate it so this is a canal go here
with Tom from and have a good day thanks
very much
[Music]